reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey mandalorian is finally here by
the way just want to say Disney Plus in
general is awesome I mean Disney chill
apparently no just a crit rate as it's
peddling an hour breezing that is in the
remaster quality itself yeah we're gonna
only have reaction highlights for this
this video is gonna be edited by our
buddy
Eric over at nerd chronic he's done work
for people like movie trivia Schmo down
Eman snow akka Siamese edited several of
our videos for the shows that we cover
that go up on YouTube full-length TV
show reactions stream alongs when you
sync up with the timecode and such will
be available at our patreon page over
got patient overdue weekly Q&A s and TV
show reaction streaming longs for many
shows like agents of shield stranger
things season three Gotham Cobra Kai
season two hunting of Hill House season
one and there are several shows that we
actually do have reaction highlights
included as the option as well like
you'll see for this Mandalorian video
and those shows are supernatural Death
Note Code Geass hunter hunter my hero
academia movie included Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on Titan
and one punch man he does music video
reactions weekly so go to our patreon
page one thought it's the foolish dream
it all you know I'm trying to say I'm
just too excited let's watch this show
neuro gotta give it up
[Music]
dr. Kaku Haase we gonna murder them cool
music oh look there must be some mistake
I can get you more credits I can bring
you an alarm or I can bring you in cold
dude I love this like yo know our music
yeah cheating me right yeah I stamped
the ice if I were you
there's really something to worry about
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
super easy barely make it long as you
got that gun I think I have to use the
back tube I mean I can do it here but if
you've never seen the fledgling myth
roll evacuate your thorax
you're lucky guy trust me are we gonna
watch him go to the bathroom yeah we're
the others Thanks
it might take a while I'm molting so
that's what a Star Wars toy that looks
like
fish
but I guess that's not going to happen
this year probably not that's mean
those look like those gold Pokemon
collectibles and they used to have a
burger yeah obviously get frozen in
carbonite they should give those out at
this is how you add burgers I can do
calamari flan but I can only pay off
what's your highest bounty not much
5,000 they won't even cover fuel these
days inflation was gas prices man there
is one job deep pocket underworld all I
know is no chain cold do you want the
chit or not
I'm just gonna say Easter eggs and
assume everyone else recover has every
seen Easter eggs Zen is that an easter
egg
yeah from Star Wars I like a frightened
cat love this it's pretty Underwood this
was gathered in the Great Purge it is
good it is back with the tribe yes
meet
forged in flames or it's my style
[Laughter]
[Music]
woulda loved if they cut back to him as
a kid and he was still wearing the mask
yeah just a tinier version
[Music]
yeah that one shoulder is gonna be so
protective whoa oh man damn house are
not chopped off that Nick Nolte I will
help you alright
he's voicing this character design to
look like him
what's your cut half half the bounty to
guide half of them blurred you help
captured the blurred you can keep them
both no need one to ride he's gonna
write a blurred it's impossible to pass
without a blurred boat I don't have time
for this
you have a landspeeder or speeder bike
that I could hire you are a Mandalorian
your ancestors rode the great myth the
sword
surely you can ride this yo really
should re-watch that holiday special
[Music]
[Applause]
it really is a Mandalorian haha
[Music]
it's like a rocky song that is where
you'll find your quarry does look like I
want to end all my sentences like that
now that's right hmm
you really doesn't like droids I have a
suggestion proceed we split the reward
this is acceptable great now let's
regroup out of harm's way and former
plans Oh
oh just work together guys
give us a badass action see
[Applause]
I hope they partner up there on Bishop
damn is like Christian Bale for
equilibrium it appears we are trapped
I will initiate self-destruct sequencing
something struck your what self-destruct
do not self-destruct come for me
I will initiate self-destruct do not
took the truck we're shooting our way
out okay
stop it stop stop
oh no oh [ __ ] he's gonna use it yeah
yeah buddy I am like selling love with
the designs here yeah cool anyone else
cuz I'm cowboy [ __ ] wait they said 50
years old perhaps that could live many
centuries
what sadly we'll never know
no the asset was to be terminated
Oh
man
he has a heart
[Music]
a date for loading directive uncle Sher
Singh
I'm glad the relation to episodes in one
week because like this whole episode is
just a bunch of reestablishing setting
up I mean there are still some questions
the obviously this shows meant to leave
you with some questions a mystery
especially like baby
yeah it's obviously Yoda but it's
whatever species that Yoda is which I'm
sure more hardcore Star Wars nuts who
are more into the lore will probably
have a better sense for everything the
advertised in the trailer I thought they
really did fulfill an honor here with
this pilot episode sometimes you get
these cool trailers and I was like
hoping this show would be more on the
slower moving Western type of vibe
especially when your main character is a
bounty hunter in space and I feel like
overall with the world they have set up
for us in this first episode they have
really delivered and I thought in the
latter parts of this episode like the
last ten minutes or we start to get a
little bit more of the personality and
the emotional flare like when he's
getting the best car steal put on his
armor and then you're seeing like these
flashbacks and these little nuggets of
though this guy has a really traumatized
background because I was getting a
little bit concerned with you know like
this is a quiet show and I'm while I
love the atmosphere and the tone and the
mood and the visuals are beautiful and I
think it does have this gritty aesthetic
to it like obviously the show won't go
into some hard our territory they did
deliver on giving us a more grim looking
side of the underworld more grounded
section of the Star Wars universe which
I do love like I'm in love with that
like it's easy when you see Star Wars
stuff to talk about the visuals the
practical effects and the aesthetics and
stuff but they're captured in a
different kind of life here and I think
that's a big part of the draw when your
main characters not really speaking that
much and when you don't get to see his
face I'm all for like the silent type
characters like a Ryan Gosling like
character or whatever but you know
without the emotion there sometimes I
felt like okay am I gonna feel detached
am I gonna feel a little bit cold
towards this but I did notice like
especially when he's interacting with IG
11 getting more of his on edge paranoid
fuel with his dialogue that
really liked every time Pedro Pascal was
talking I love his delivery when he's
getting more emotional and more intense
I really like that there's a great
mystery wrap around to this but yeah and
I've been talking a lot John let me let
you talk go talk no I think that's a
great point John more to say really
nicely and the biggest impression it
left on me was that it really nicely
encapsulated all of those Western tones
because yeah you have your silent hero
who only speaks when it's absolutely
necessary or is very economical with his
speaking you know you see all these
different Western tropes play out you
know he's stranded in the desert he gets
attacked by an animal is to learn to
tame a horse or a blurred in this case
you know he forms a momentary
partnership with somebody and then you
know ends it as soon as it leaves his
best interests I thought they did a
really nice job of just drawing out the
underworld and the desert the less
populated side of the universe it feels
very distinct but it also feels very
Star Wars I feel like in the films and
stuff we see a lot of big cities and
planets that are bustling and stuff like
that so even though this wasn't
necessarily the most action-packed
premiere and there is definitely a few
solid action sequences I did like
spending time in the life of like whoa
what is it like to be this bounty hunter
character on these solitary missions
that the intro is good you know what
what kind of regular day and day-out
bounty is he probably on and then seeing
as things escalate into some kind of
serious underworld bounty that we're
working on here I hope we get to see
more of Verna Hertzog and I did think it
was an interesting detail that the
droids orders were to absolutely kill
the baby
and it seemed as though her talks people
want to keep that baby alive yeah and
that's an intriguing you know little
point of conflict that I have to imagine
will grow well it seems like they're
taking a little bit more of these like
traditional action hero movie traile ike
you have a target and then he finds the
target and i can't kill the target you
know that kind of element to set up the
show with this action here and then
classic western vibes as well and we
were talking about that thought the
beginning was really smart i'm not just
establishing tone but really setting up
our character because at first i thought
they were doing a save the cat thing
like okay he's going to show up be a
badass and then this guy
he was explained yeah and I thought that
was a clever mislead because it sets him
up like oh he's a hero look look what he
did he took out these bad guys and save
this tooth oh wait he's actually here to
capture yeah yeah I thought yeah that
was really clever but what I will want
more from this show as it progresses
because I'm very much aware like this is
the pilot this is the first episode I
think it's very intentional why they
want to release two episodes in one week
yeah because it seems like now in the
next episode that's when we're gonna get
a lot of the emotional pull a lot of the
emotional stakes at hand because teasing
the depth of our main character I think
it's really smart and how they're
handling you you do start off as a
silent cold type what you expect from
Mandalorian bounty hunter character and
then the tease of the flashback the way
he's reacting in a high-stakes situation
even kind of warming up to IG 11 which
gyroid so it has a chance of coming back
you know it's something struck just
maybe there's another one or it gets
right yeah because I like the idea of
them teaming up or working together
because this Mandalorian character runs
by his own rules and then IG 11 is all
about obeying the rules and it's like
you can't really sway the Droid because
it's droid as I like the idea of those
two working together and warming up to
that but then him also seeing that it's
a baby and being sensitive to that as
well or even a little nugget of giving
money or whatever the currency was to
Nick Nolte's characters saying stuff
like you deserve it you know see more of
this depth they're like these little
details that you pick up on or even when
he is a bonding with the blerg which I
thought the design was great the music
played up this like heroic triumphant
tune to it I didn't really feel like I
was feeling that I was like the music's
making me feel that but this scenes not
really making me feel that if I'm being
totally honest but I kind of wonder if
you're yeah when he's like fine riding
it that could have been stretched or
something more fleshed a little bit but
I not the point I imagine for Star Wars
fans who are a little bit more exposed
to the lore of you know the Mandalore's
cry might feel something more for that
moment of like yeah legacy stuff cuz
he's like he even brought it up Nick
Nolte's character and Carl Weathers I
thought was really cool too like
everyone seems like they're on the right
vibe here yeah all in the right tone and
then the right headspace for this no one
feels out of place yeah and if certain
characters don't come back I don't
necessarily think that's bad either cuz
one of the interesting things is you are
travelling through so many distant
places and especially in a Western
scenario it's all about distance too I
wonder who's gonna come back and win cuz
you know they got a lot of profile
actors to fill these supporting
characters they're all pretty
interesting everybody they got to show
up here made some kind of impression so
I don't know I I wouldn't be surprised
either way I guess if we did or didn't
see some of these people cuz like Nick
Nolte seems kind of like he's in a very
specific position we might see him as
you know the Mandalorian chose to leave
this planet but I'm curious as to how
this unfolds I don't have like a million
predictions off the bat so I definitely
not yeah I feel like there's still stuff
they have to establish that oh it'd make
a little bit more clear - yeah yeah you
know because it takes place like a
little bit after Return of the Jedi I
think that when it comes to any
nostalgic vibes it's really just from
being in the Star Wars world and being
back into this more grounded atmosphere
because this feels and looks like
cinematography wise music wise tone
pacing wise very different from the
original trilogy I'd say at least you
know but I think the nostalgic vibes do
come in form of some of the designs and
the practical effects and the makeup and
then certain creatures that you're
seeing here and there I like that it
wasn't focusing at all on Skywalker for
things are Jedi it's it is doing its own
thing and I think for a setup this was
exactly what it needed to be now I'm
just hoping I'm more hooked into you
know character building for the next
episode yeah I mean I can definitely
first see them wanting to increase and
build that as the show goes along but i
weirdly did feel like I was watching
something akin to the older Star Wars a
lot more than a lot of the more recent
Star Wars stuff even though this isn't
totally the same or visually the design
sense is the same but it's not visually
the same but even so weirdly this felt
yeah more spiritually akin to those than
a lot of the recent films to me for
whatever reason if I'm more naturally
akin it felt more definitely and I think
it's I think it's in the way that it
like there's something about the pacing
it's like you know the original Star
Wars films are rollicking but I feel
like the newer ones are paced
differently and orchestrated with a
different sense of yet loss as think to
having prominent puppet characters and
stuff like that like Nick Nolte you can
tell that he's a puppet and his mouth
doesn't quite work oh yeah I'm pretty
sure it is the way by the way especially
when the mouth was moved like the mouth
was informing in a way that matched yeah
and they do that in the new movies but
just like things like that ik they all
came together to make this feel like a
natural extension of Star Wars that has
new things involved yeah and props too
just if that's paid for Pascal or
whoever just the body language
I thought he'd hit Wow oh yeah he's
definitely a he stuff in the suit you
know I bet he opted to make sure the
mass number comes off so that way no one
could ever tell when there's a stunt
double yeah that way Karl Urban can
fight for cred yeah yeah all those
agencies it was always made always me
I've learned all the stuff and in terms
of grounded action with like blasters
and stuff this is some of my favorite
the Star Wars movies I think I often
think of the big space battles or the
Jedi fights but the blaster action you
know like I think one did a pretty cool
job I don't know if like I would
consider this the best of it however I
feel like this show is probably gonna
offer the best we've seen yeah yeah I
feel like you see a lot of blasters in
Star Wars held by characters who cannot
aim every stormtrooper and thus they
feel very unimportant and then when
you're thinking of you know combat
hand-to-hand you're thinking lightsabers
so here you're dealing with people who
are all blaster folks yeah some of the
choreography in the stage setting of it
was some of the best as opposed to just
hide shoot hi yes you alright guys well
did you like the first episode the
Mandalorian are you excited for it
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell you notify have you got a youtube
video up make sure to check us on
patreon for all those reactions that we
talked about including this one and I'd
like to end this with a patron of the
day shout out to a woman named Adelia
Chamberlin Adelia I know you got your
Disney Plus subscription I know you're a
huge huge Star Wars fan and I just
wanted to end this one on a very sincere
note what saying I really appreciate you
I love chatting with you
I know sometimes you feel like that when
we're talking are we having too much of
a lengthy dialogue back and forth but I
just think you're very sweet and you
really connect with me and you mean I do
you mean a lot I'm gonna get teary don't
look at me a lot to me so I just wanted
to say thank you for you know being you
and being willing to be both man I'm you
okay you're the man to Chamberlain
you're the man to Chamberlain and you're
gonna bring our hearts in dead or alive
maybe shadows supposed to be funny and
I'm like okay heartfelt is just as good
look at all those late night shows who
get serious once in a while thank you
Delia Rock much love